heyo Sanji catch here and today for this
tie to Tuesday I'm actually not gonna be
analyzing the tire Tuesday private
project instead we're actually to go
over the tidy models on package so
recently that tie Devers developers and
data science team has released an
ensemble package called tidy models and
it's essentially a a it's like the tidy
verse except for machine learning so you
can do all these modeling procedures in
one package this is actually the
successor to the carrot package which
was kind of like the default black box
modeling package where you do we train
multiple models that's at us at a single
like framework and Max Kuhn who is
actually the developer all the care
packages on his team so tidy models from
now on is gonna be it's the successor
that to the carrot package so I think
it'd be interesting to kind of go over
the basics of Tidy models and just kind
of do a sum comparing and contrasting
with tied models and carrot so we're
gonna use the abalone dataset which is a
pretty popular kind of like Toy Machine
warning data set that's why I guess UC
Irvine's machine learning repository and
you just need to go to the data folder
and download the abalone data file okay
so so we're just gonna open up a
markdown file we're gonna rename this to
tidy Tuesday carrot and tidy models okay
I'm gonna make sure to what's here I'm
gonna make sure it I have my directory
set so I can get it set as working
directory okay so okay so I'm gonna do
the I'm gonna right load in the tidy
verse tidy models and the carrot package
okay and also I'm gonna do Redux read
underscore CSV it'll be a baloney data
and since for the the abalone data file
it doesn't actually have call names it's
it's mostly just like it's like that
we're gonna have to specify the actual
column names and if we will get the
column names it's all this stuff but I
actually have the list saved so I'm just
gonna copy and paste it soon to not
waste any time
okay so now we have this and with the
abalone data set the me it's actually
our I believe a regression data set
we're trying to predict the amount of
rings in the abalone and the Rings is a
century I guess your age of the abalone
I guess it's like a muscle or something
like that abalone yeah it's like a it's
like a snail okay and I guess the Rings
are kind of the age of it cool we're
just going to do some basic
pre-processing so DF we need sex to be
as a factor so we'll do that
additionally there's about 4,000 rows
and it's since I'm gonna be doing some
modeling I'm gonna just remove some of
it so I'm gonna do set C don't say 80
say DF sample and yeah and I'm just
gonna use 800 simples um it's not really
a great you know I wouldn't probably do
a bunch of Michigan learning models on
just a sample size I have 800 without
doing some type of procedures for it but
this is just for you know comparing so
we're not working on will sleep over
that do a basic summary statistics of it
we have a length diameter Hyatt hallway
shucked weight viscera way shell way and
then the Rings with a man and a max of
two and 24 we also have relatively even
genders so there's not a disparity
between that FIM female male and maybe
eyes they're just kind of like unknown
so we can go through that
it's infants so infant cool okay
I bet infinitely related to the rings
but that's not really what we're trying
to go over okay
so modeling procedure 101 is you first
have to create your you're training in
your test sets right so you want to
train a model off of a tree off of
training data and then you want to
evaluate it based off the test data okay
so we're gonna do it first we're gonna
do it the the carat way so with carat
you just make a you use the data
partition
I'm function so we'll say carat split
create oops create data partition why so
DF will say rings P equals point will do
80/20 split this equals false so we have
a carat split right so as always like
resampling stuff going on it's okay we
don't we don't want to go through that
okay so to create those tests training
test bullets will do karat train and
then we'll say DF and we'll index the
rows by the carat splits okay that's
fine this is just kind of a kind of
arguing about like tables and stuff like
that we don't really need to worry about
that
test like a test set and we'll say
whatever you did for those rows we're
not gonna use those rows that were using
the train sets so we save - what okay
and if we see carrot train dimensions
641 with nine columns which makes sense
and then we do that test 159 nine
columns cool so that's the carrot way to
do it so splitting train and test sets
with care
and then we have the tidy models way
which is used initial split right what's
interesting about it tidy models is most
of the always kind of like steps and
processes and actual modeling are are in
different packages so there's there's a
package for just like doing data
partitioning right there's a package for
actually tuning your parameters and
there's like a package for making them
models and there's another package to do
on the evaluations it's kind of
interesting but you don't have to worry
about like which package goes with with
what thing um it's all in the tidy
models central package okay so we're
gonna call this this tidy split and
we'll say initial split and it just
takes out the data so we'll just say VF
and prop equals and won't say 0.8 and
what's cool about I guess this is it's a
little bit easier to understand what's
going on so to create the Train Set you
don't actually do this you just say
training and you give it the the split
from it and then you for test you do
testing and used to give it again the
same split okay so if we look at tidy
trained in its 641 same thing right okay
so that's the tidy way so splitting
train and tests that's what tidy well
with I'm gonna say the tidy way okay so
when we're starting it's nothing crazy I
would say you know basically the same
way pretty efficient on both ends
honestly I wouldn't really sleep if you
did this way or that way but I kind of
like this because you can use this
actual split for other things in the
tidy framework okay so once we have our
trainer tests
training and test sets we actually need
to apply some pre-processing most models
it really doesn't hurt
you know Saturn's scale or normalizer
data to surround different dimensions
for this one it's pretty much I would
say centered and centered but we can
just keep on doing it so with the caret
way what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna apply it
Center and scaling to all values besides
our target variable which will be Rings
we also have to create W variables for
this sex so that's it's gonna say like
female it goes 0 or 1 right and we're
gonna do one hot encoding because we're
gonna do a random forest model and
normally if you're doing the color just
stick with Oh linear regression you
should probably do like a dummy variable
thing where you have some degrees of
freedom where it's only if you have
three categorical values it would be two
so beep female male and then if female
or zero then it'd be implying it be
infant but this way we're just gonna do
it very simple will be female infant or
male zeroes and ones for all of them
okay so we're gonna say pre-processing
Center scale and one hot and code okay
okay so first we're gonna do the what to
do the pre-processing processing we care
it we're actually use the pre process
function there's pretty simple
so we'll say since we're gonna be
modeling it using the training data
we're always going to use to training
stuff so we can apply it to the test set
we don't really want to have any data
leakage so we wouldn't want to do the
pre-processing values on the entire set
if that makes sense
ideally the splits will make it so it
doesn't it shouldn't make a difference
but it's better to just do it based off
the train set and you should never
really use a test set for any modeling
stuff okay so we're gonna deselect the
Rings because we don't want to apply the
pre-processing to the Rings so we do
that and then we'll say method equals
see Center and scale so they're right
it's pre processing center scaled yada
yada
okay so carrot pre-process okay and
we're gonna apply that into that into a
little object and this is actually some
type of like you can use this to predict
on to it or to kind of like apply the
actual reprocessing
so we'll say carrot train equals predict
carrot pre-process and we'll use our
carrot train data okay so we apply ooh I
just feel like air train wrong carrot
train and then we'll do the same thing
to our test set pre-process okay boom so
we applied pre-processing using our
training data on both our train and test
sets for our carrot modeling service so
if we look at our carrot train we still
have our categorical or factored
variables so we still need to apply the
one hot encoding so we'll say apply one
hot encoding using carrot and with
carrot they use the dummy VARs function
and we say dummy VARs data equals carrot
train so that's saying if we if you see
a factor we're gonna create into a dummy
variable and there's an option to make
it so it's not one hot encoding I think
it's called
drop second so we can say like oh we we
can say drop what was it key I don't
know it's it's something like that where
it's like drop second equals it feels
true but we don't really need to worry
about that since we're not going to be
doing that so okay
carrot one hot dummy bars boom okay now
we're gonna to we'll just apply this one
huh encoding to all of our data
so I'd carrot train see one hand cut
everything is still
and scaled and then we still have our
rings that which are untouched
okay so we'll say karat train boom
carrot test do the same thing to our
carrot test data to our carrot data okay
so that's our pre-processing that we're
gonna do for modeling with the tidy
models so we'll say tidy way of the
pre-process see they actually use a
thing called the recipes package which
has all of these kind of like
pre-processing the styles and they do it
in like steps and essentially what it's
saying is this pre-processing is
basically a recipe where you're trying
to like add different ingredients to it
to create your final model data okay so
the recipe starts with recipe we have to
specify our formula so recipes is we're
gonna predict rings using the formula
our data will be tidy train data and
then this is a this is what's really
cool is since it's a tidy models it's
basically made to be pipe into things so
what we're gonna do we're gonna add
Center and we're gonna say all
predictors - all nominal and all nominal
is like all categorical variables I
guess so we don't want to apply the
center and scaling to our dummy
variables and then we're gonna do is
step scale same thing all predictors -
all nominal and then step dummy all
nominal - all OH
Allen domino and then we also don't want
to apply it - yeah let's just do it and
then we'll say one hunt he goes true
cool so now we have a recipe so it's
saying go centering scaling dummy
okay and then we have to prep so there's
things where I'm not really sure what
house works but basically this is the
recipe where it's also not really doing
anything right it's just saying like
here's what we did we actually have to
prep the recipe so we'll call this tidy
prep equals prep tidy rep okay oops oh I
need call us tidy wreck tidy I'm gonna
call this tidy wreck or tidy recipe
right okay so we have our our recipe
prepped great so now it's really saying
okay okay here's what's going on we're
gonna Center and scale these things
right we're gonna scale these again
and then we're gonna create dummy
variables from the sex right so that's
now it's looking at our data and saying
okay how am I gonna apply this recipe
what are the what are the predictors
what other nominals what where all it
was everything right and then we can
also say tidy juice which if you notice
we don't actually have anything it's
just saying outcome predictor like
where's my actual process data asked
that's when we have to juice our data
and we do juice tidy prep and boom we
have tidy juice and then it applied all
that stuff to it or we have our one hot
encoded variables our Center and scaled
data with our rings that's untouched
cool so you can see that um your you
might be wondering like okay well what's
did I mean it's cool that this is like
able to be pipe and stuff but it's like
what's the point of how is the tidy way
how is the tidy model is better than
carrot well for example when we apply
the center in scaling we don't really
know how it's supposed to be treating
every variable we might want to actually
only Center say our heights and only
scale our diameters and with the tidy
way we can we don't have to do all
predictors we can all say like starts
with you know contains stuff like that
or we say oh all nominal so there's more
fine-tuning in a more intuitive fashion
where this this carrot way it's almost
kind of like a black box for you
like I'll just do it you won't care how
it happens you just wanted to do it okay
cool Plus these recipes we just have
Center and scaling but there is much
cooler things for for the pre-processing
like if we look at our references we
have you know has roll all predictors
also if we have some some stuff like
that
we have imputation x' impute a lower
threshold mean imputation mode
imputation rolling window stuff you know
you can you can do more complex
transformations you do box-cox I don't
even know what this what this is right
inverse right inverse ax Blodgett
a lot of really cool transformations you
can do like a regular transformation on
it right again and then there's also
more things so you can say like you can
create dates counts you can do
interaction effects so there's a lot of
really cool stuff that you can do like
step interact so if I want to do is say
interactions between you know the gender
and diameter we can add that if we
wanted to see like terms equals carbon
hydrogen hydrogen stuff like that so
yeah there and there's also there's a
ton of just really cool stuff where I
mean you could go through like a
month-long education course about it but
we don't really care about that okay
that's just there's the basics of it
okay so now that we have our
pre-processed data for both carat and
tidy models we're gonna start doing our
sampling procedures so one of the ways
that carrots carrots main framework is
basically create a train and test set
and then with that train set use k-fold
cross-validation to figure out the best
tuning parameters so if you're in a
modeling or data mining class you might
have heard of like oh we're gonna do
this the train validation and test set
that's essentially what cables hostile
agent is doing so that's why they only
split it in to a training test the folds
are acting
as a validation set and it's a little
bit better RPS you can do it ten times
so you have a more robust estimate of
your error and parameter hyper parameter
tuning okay so we're actually to set our
sampling procedures using K folds okay
so for carat it's pretty simple you say
train control method equals repeated cv
repeats equals ten number equals ten and
that's how you do it
so we'll say carrot K folds boom okay so
if we look at carrot K folds we have all
that stuff right kind of a kind of dirty
you only want to read this stuff it's
looks like there's a lot you know stuff
in it for the tidy way they use a v-fold
CV which is basically the same thing so
we'll say tidy train v equals ten strata
equals I'm gonna say rings because our
thing is based off of rings so tidy K
folds okay
so again it's not rows and you can see
how I made the folds already right
partitioned it okay so it's again not
not crazy they're doing the same thing
this one it's not actually giving you
the data it's gonna do that in the
actual modeling procedure whereas in the
tidy way it already creates the data and
then we're gonna put that that K folds
thing into the actual model stuff okay
but again pretty pretty simple nothing's
changed too much however for the actual
modeling then we kind of get into some
different waters okay so we're gonna say
tuning models okay so we're gonna do
what we do the carrot for us we're gonna
go carrot first so we'll say carrot RF
train rings so that's our formula we're
going to
predict rings using our training data
we're going to model it to our method
will be random forests which is the
random forest package we're not going to
use range or anything like that and our
train control is equal to carat cross a
carat was it K folds and we're gonna
just set our tuned length equals three
so it's gonna try three different I
guess M tries and this might take a
while because I told just did not enable
parallel processing but that's fine okay
so while it's training we're actually
gonna do we're gonna start writing out
the the tidy model this way so I'm gonna
first say create a model a crate plus a
create random forest bottle in carat
okay the random forest model and carat
is pretty easy and honestly I kind of
like it better than the actual tidy way
because it's very straightforward right
I think most people could read this and
say okay I get it
like I get what you're doing but it's
not as flexible right so the tidy way
would be we're gonna say we're gonna
choose a ran forest and how we're gonna
tune it is we're going to say okay our
we're gonna tune our M tree or M try
we're gonna let the model tidy verse
kind of tiny models tune it but we're
also gonna give it trees and for our
trees we're gonna specify say like I
don't know 1000 trees and then min n
we're gonna let again tidy verse tidy
models tune that thing okay and then
we're gonna have to set the mode and
since we're trying to predict a rings
which is like a continuous variable one
we're gonna say oh it's a regression and
for our engine we can set our engine to
random forest engine well it's cool like
this is we don't actually have to choose
a random forest engine we can actually
choose
tidy models we can actually choose
different engines which is really nice
especially when you can think of how you
might prefer say like I'm Ranger instead
of random for us and stuff like that so
if we look at you see parsnip right you
can set your engines so yeah you can you
can set all this cool stuff you there's
a model as to so it's pretty easy to
reference they have like Eris stuff c4
random forests they just have random
forests if you look at it for random
forests you can say okay these are the
things that they give it give you you
can say Ranger or random forest and you
can also use spark yeah so if we also go
back we can see that there's also some
cool things so there's like a you can do
like a stand back end following your
aggression so if you're into that like
like Bayesian statistics and stuff like
that you can do cool stuff like that
okay so yeah as you can see there's a
decent amount of models some neural nets
k-nearest neighbor let's see what else
there's you know mostly very
multivariate adaptive regression splines
GLM's
let's see what else are there yeah and
obviously you're boosted models do okay
so let's see what it's still doing okay
still still running I'm gonna I'm gonna
pause this video and then I'll resume it
went set finished training okay we'll go
to your right when I said I'm gonna stop
the video until when it finish finishes
training I finish training if you will
get the time Sam it sort of the same
time so we look at it trained it using
three different M tries
great it says like okay the best em try
our best value was six so six em tree
okay so with the random forest model
we're gonna set that so we're saying
okay we're gonna specify a random forest
model okay so let's say tidy RF and you
know if you if you know it's something
it's just like wait but we didn't
actually train anything we just have a
model skeleton okay and this is the
thing that's a little odd um and I think
I'm gonna have to start getting used to
you have to actually do a tidy workflow
um it's basically saying since we're
giving it all these data splits we need
it to kind of understand how to model
this stuff so we give it a workflow so
say okay our workflow is we're going to
give it a recipe or pre-processing
process and that's our tidy recipe and
we're going to add a model and that
model is our tidy RF model okay so we
have a tie to workflow so let's specify
modeling procedure specify model that
was a tidy way okay and then finally to
actually tune it we're gonna stay tuned
the model and to tune the model we
actually do the a tune grid we give it
our tight our tidy workflow we give it
our re samples or our like
cross-validation stuff so if we were
reference it's tidy k folds and then for
our grid search we're gonna say grid
will state grid equals and we'll say
grid equals five okay so we'll say tidy
tune boom so now it's tuning um the
models off of a grid that we created I'm
using K folds okay I'm saying five tried
to five different things so while it's
training the models we're gonna actually
go and
probably create a new section now let's
say evaluates D models okay so I'm gonna
let this go um actually we might guess
keep on going through here oh yeah
that's that's what else won't I go over
one cool thing about the tidy models
package is it actually comes with some
other things such as where is its text
recipes so there's actually some text
it's Roy they made it so it's pretty
easy to actually do some text mining so
the if you look at it says step
tokenized so after do all the
tokenization for you remove this stop
words you can do like um max N and you
can also do a tf-idf thing right there
and this is because like all the people
who were creating this I've also created
a tidy text package okay so if you
notice there's like oh you can do word
embeddings which is very very cool so
you can kind of get some stay over they
are modeling stuff if you if you give it
some word embeddings yeah let's see if
there's anything there's anything cool
that we can come look at first before we
go look at it
yeah so one thing that I'm thinking that
they're gonna try to do is with boredom
Eddings they might be able to in like
embeddings we're seeing betting's it is
they do some cooler things such as I was
some like neural network like hugging
face stuff but you never know okay so
our model has been trained because it's
creating pre browsing data final final
inside okay whatever
so if we look at tidy tune we have all
of our splits all over fold with a
metrics and some notes okay and it says
oh we use 10-fold cross-validation using
stratification cool so first um we're
gonna evaluate our carrot model so let's
say evaluate carrot model so carrot RF
pretty cool
can we plot it out yep we can plot it
out best best value is six right
lowest root mean squared error is that
okay so we have our plot of that cool of
it tuning you can see that's probably
you know the max the the best the best
primer you know let's just look at it
like okay look at the MA e on average
when it has six when it uses that
parameter of six it's off by 1.7 cool
okay so now let's do the evaluate the
type of be tidy bottle so with the tidy
model we look at tidy tune there's
actually some cool things you can do so
we can say it select best and we say
okay with the metric we want the best
rmse and it does it right it says m try
of 7 with a min n of 33 so that's their
best tuning right Howie best tune
cool so now we actually want to kind of
finalize a model so let's say finalize
our models we already know that our care
our F we can say final model C is numb
trees 6 yada yada um and it'll
automatically use the best model
basically it says final minute model is
that so we kind of have to worry about
the care 1 however for the tidy way we
can say we have to do a different thing
okay so we say um if we look at our tidy
our F it doesn't actually have any
tuning parameters since we we we were
trying to tune it based off the tire
tune so we're gonna have to add these
new tuning parameters from our tidy best
tune right so we will get tidy best tune
it has it right em tree in maintenance
we need to give it that ok so we're
gonna do this we're gonna use a function
that they were smart a bit that they
knew that people were gonna be using
right they know people are gonna be
tuning models and you want to apply that
final tuning parameter to their model so
this function called they finalize model
we give it our original model and then
we give it the new parameters which is
tidy best tune and boom see it's updated
7 and 33 ok so let's say tidy final
model cool so once you have a tidy final
model we have to make an effort final
workflow since we were training off of
our workflow we need to create another
workflow because our model is different
which is a little confusing to be honest
and I'm sure there's a there's a reason
for it but if you notice that with the
tide I'm like why do I always delete
this if you notice what the tidy models
there's so much things to read about and
since they just released it it's gonna
be kind of and to me it's gonna take a
few months for everyone to kind of like
figure out the process they're probably
gonna make some fixes they're gonna
probably make some changes to the
function names
stuff okay so we need to make a final
workflow so was a tidy final work work
work flow work flow function and recipe
it's still the same recipe but this time
we add a model and this is our tidy
final model okay and we look at our tidy
I don't work for them
What's it saying saying okay we're gonna
pre-process it using our given recipe
our model is a random forest we're gonna
send our scaling dummy it and we're
gonna give these parameters okay so
we're gonna say tidy so now we need to
actually know like okay so we have our
final model when you test our actual
models right so let's say that say
evaluate the test sets using the final
final models all right easy
so for carrot it's a little weird so if
we do some predict you know carrot RF
which is our final model with the carrot
test it gives you a list of all all this
garbage right so we always have to
convert it to like as a table all right
I will see buying our carrot test as
kibble select was it rings and we'll say
obvious equals that right so ah blows
that as that table I'll say select and
we'll say pred equals one okay so we
have our final model we have our prior
to one you see it's it's it's kind of
looking right but this one's obviously
very wrong but we'll say that so we'll
say I'm carrot final results and we are
gonna evaluate through our MSC we'll use
carrots function
for our embassy for the carrot stuff so
our pred is equal to carrot final
results Fred our observe is carrot final
results observed and we calculate is
2.29 does that make any sense
since realistically a good model should
I basically have this similar validation
and test accuracy so let's look at it so
carrot our right carrot RF two point
three four two point two nine I think
that's pretty solid in fact it's a
little bit lower cool so now let's say
evaluate so this is a carrot way care it
away so for the actual tidy way and
we'll we'll do thanks to what do I need
that stuff okay and finally for the tidy
way we still have our tidy model or tidy
workflow what's cool about this is they
know like they know oh yeah like we're
gonna have to evaluate on the test set
there's also this cool function called
the last fit which is our last we did
all of our modeling tuning this is our
last fit we finally are gonna put it to
the test set and to actually give it to
find the test that we're actually gonna
use the tightest bullets all right and
it actually evaluates on the test set so
we have our trained test with like that
okay and then we can actually do is
collect metrics and boom we have our
test metrics from our test set so it's
pretty it's pretty straightforward and
we see oh it's two point four four so we
know it's that two point two nine so so
our actual carrot is a little bit better
but still we actually didn't give it as
much tuning parameter so uh with random
forests isn't gonna are the carrot
weighs it takes took a lot longer than
the actual tidy way and we can always do
more tuning okay we are specified the
trees but if we
it's kind of tuned the trees too I'm
sure would find a better model but if
you know something how it's definitely
pretty easy to evaluate these models
that in the tidy way but the actual
amount of procedure seems a little bit
more complex that's because I think it's
really made to train multiple models at
the same time with the same procedure on
the same data additionally I think some
problems with the Tidy model package is
that there's a lot of functions that you
just like it makes sense but there's so
many so many ways to say it that you're
like I don't even know how like what
function I'm really looking for so
there's gonna be a lot of referencing
the actual package that's fine because
they have they've made some great
documentation
additionally um the grid the tune grid
is a little confusing with a workflow I
think I still need to kind of really
understand how the workflow works um but
the greatest the really good things that
I like but the the tidy models framework
is that they really make it so you can't
really mess with the test set so it's
it's there or trying to make it so like
you're not cheating on your actual
modeling procedures so yeah um that was
basically this is basically a short
video of just kind of going over the
basics of the tiny models and carrot
package one thing that I think would be
kind of interesting to do is basically
um a good I think a good way to kind of
dip your toes into it is really kind of
learn the recipes package right and do
all the pre-processing using recipes
like this and then just juicing it like
that so doing like doing up to this and
then if you don't feel comfortable doing
say they tidy model apart you can just
use the juiced data on your carrot stuff
and just train models through carrot I
think that's a good way to kind of start
getting a hang of how how the type
models works so yeah um yeah there's a
short video but I really liked Italian
models package and I'm probably going to
keep on working on it um probably also
probably make a video on the Charis
package because the tidy models
really reminds you of Karis - so I will
not be messing with that in the future
so yeah yeah I'll see us next weekend
Teddy on